ils sont venus nombreux à la salle
malherbe de maisons laffitte plusieurs
générations ont fait le déplacement des
quatre coins des yvelines pour venir
écouter les conférences de quatre
personnalités politiques tout porte
parole d'eric zemmour je crois
qu'aujourd'hui la france elle a besoin
d'abord d'un homme courageux et c'est
précisément je dirais ce qu'est eric
zemmour je pense qu'aujourd'hui il a ce
courage d'avoir posé un diagnostic
lucide de proposer des solutions qui
sont claires qui sont cohérentes on ne
peut plus se contenter du dut en même
temps auquel nous a tristement habitués
emmanuel macron le président de la
république doit fixer une vision dans la
une fixer un cap d'action y en a une
veiller à ce que les principales
décisions qui sont de son ressort soient
mises en oeuvre appliqués et suis dit
comme il convient que lille ne veut
comme le peuple français l'a voulu une
soirée pour mettre en avant une union
des droites pour le parti reconquête
comme le mouvement conservateur l'ia ou
encore le cni p
l'objectif faire barrière à la
république en marche le mouvement
conservateur a été depuis sa fondation
attaché vraiment à une ligne politique
constante et cohérente et c'est ce qu'on
a trouvé chez eric zemmour stanislas
rigaud président de génération z le
mouvement jeunes de reconquête étaient
également présents pour représenter la
jeunesse je crois que cette élection
présidentielle ce n'est pas un candidat
de plus il va jouer c'est réellement la
venue d'autres pays et nous en tant que
jeune en tant que 16 30 ans c'est
véritablement notre avenir qui va se
mettre en place le choix société dans
lequel nous allons vivre doit être pris
maintenant en 2022 et c'est pourquoi
j'invite tous les jeunes à 1
s'intéressent elles sont prises en ciel
allait s'inscrire sur les listes
électorales et peut-être mars aller
voter et accessoires ans vous pouvez
aller voter une campagne qui s'accélère
pour le candidat qui dans la même
journée à gagner des points dans les
sondages selon une enquête harris
interactive pour challenge le candidat
dépasse maintenant valérie pécresse et
se place numéro trois derrière emmanuel
macron et marine le pen à moins de deux
mois du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle